في عالم المال ورجال الاعمال النمو الاكبر
بين اثرياء العالم هذا العام كان من نصيب
مؤسس فيسبوك مؤشر
للمليارديرات حتى ما اعرف اقولها قدرها
نسبه نمو ثروه مارك زوكربيرج بنحو 44
مليار دولار لتقارب تقارب 90 مليار دولار
بس ضئيل يعني الحقيقه على كل حال وفقا
للمؤشر فان الرئيسه التنفيذي لمتى يحتل
الان المرتبه الثانيه عشره بين اثرياء
العالم
ياتي هذا النمو القياسي بعد ان فقد جوكر
بيرج اكثر من نصف ثروته العام الماضي بسبب
انخفاض عدد مستخدمي منصه
عشره مليار عشره مليار دولار ما تعني شيء
بالنسبه لشخصيتها حياه سعيده مصرف جيب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصر الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات